welcome to the show look at that hippie
I've never seen your legs I know thank
God I requested you on this I know we're
not we're not thrilled with you it's
been a rough morning all right how's
that oh it's beautiful it's the Borgata
but if you weren't here I think I'm
driving but you know what I mean yeah
you really think this is gonna make his
showbiz career Radio with Ricky because
he's generous he gets good comedy he can
see a fraud he knows I asked what's he
wearing but they didn't they didn't say
a baseball cap on backwards and that is
a thrill right with my body your head
and neck and his hands we could make one
good turtle I mean we've been trying to
talk about just about anything but
somehow progressively through the
morning we started okay the wheels came
off after the first break I mean rich
has been slowly taking off those little
lug nuts ever since he got you're
supposed to take control like Opie did
you don't take control you didn't over
your reference yeah you got over once
it's not gonna get over we stood last
week not just that was literally one
side oh no here's the thing you tell me
you asked me to go to Vimeo log on I've
never done on my stupid phone I could
barely see he's upset about stuff today
and he's upset about other stuff okay
we're supposed to pay for my little
pay for your ones lobotomy my hotel it
was great you know he's working at
Atlantic City not 20 staying okay it's
an hour away I couldn't go from AC to
the right sorry they say my hotel I get
to the hotel it goes and I pay for this
show no one does they don't even get
paid what are you kidding me complain to
the hotel they got pissed off at him no
I think I think there's been a rape up
there 130 cinema make sure I've flown in
from landing city yeah and I need a I
need a room to crash right and they said
oh it's not paid I walked out I never
been there before they said welcome mr.
Voss they knew me and I big fans and I
said yeah this is all taken care of and
they said no it's not I'm [ __ ] calm
no I'm telling you they didn't do it
the booking.com that is how you prove
you're a big actor though I'm a big star
[Laughter]
like a price I know the booking I don't
know booking I do Priceline myself
automatically you pay Priceline you go
to the hotel it's already paid for
so when the company here said they went
to booking calm I would figure psyche
Priceline already paid for
so the hotel what you do in your record
you go through Priceline shows a massive
amount of disrespect for him
his company's already doing this for
free yeah I've requested him you're here
yeah then they put him in a hotel right
that's not even how much was it there
was the bill its $183 and Ricky lability
a cash stipend right yeah this is so
you're down on the deal down I'm down
financially mentally spiritually
everything you could be down on this
emptiness when I leave no nothing just
something to fill up for Joe are you
gonna do the Phil and your like I don't
know maybe you're talking about me
saying something funny my 11 year old is
funnier this guy rich it's your job and
it's true your job is to be funny your
Camino
[Laughter]
last time I found all about yo you start
short a picture of you with no teeth the
Jericho showed me that I think Roland
showed me like Mountain Dew mouth on it
was incredible thing yeah it's lived an
incredible life but the life experience
is left him with no knowledge
[Laughter]
on stage I'm a [ __ ] monster true and
all experiences and knowledge I went
through I [ __ ] you know I don't fail
when I'm doing stand-up you crush every
time every time the majority the time
you do very well
look at the [ __ ] you see the glasses
sticker wide wide frame five pairs of
the dollar stores sometimes everything
to fifties oh is you know that they do a
you know a couple years ago 25 by 1350
he wanted this is true this is how
[ __ ] up like this is no line and it
might not be funny but it's true okay I
was getting I was getting a physical
last week a week you know you get a
physical as sure yeah so the doctor you
know he's doing and I pull my pants down
and he's touching it and I said to my
doctor it's so much nicer wonder tour
[Laughter]
and he goes I don't want to see it that
way he told me that's how I could say
anything to him anything to anyone so
hold on chance with some yeah different
every time so I probably I would never
make that sort joke okay like I know the
in case it went badly I couldn't been
you're there yeah it's not really
just killed last night Chuck if you say
to a pediatrician he gave me a prostate
check I lost it by the way busted the
finger yeah poking for sure probably I
turned around I said that's all you got
[Laughter]
you know I still I mean I'm 50 I've had
the finger now for probably eight years
and it's still awkward it's too great
yeah
it's still awkward when he says yeah can
I give you it in a van it's high up as
well like they really go for it like
it's not like you know it's like they
really push they feel like they're in
yeah yeah yeah sure the gross misses and
you know this is when they're done or
that waxy oil the oil yeah that's or the
part I hate them oh yeah dripping and
you know I mean right but you can do it
without that now they've got they can
tell in well blood test yeah yeah yeah
without the oil imagine vas giving you
look at those [ __ ] the sovereign
rings blood test yes no fun have you
done a colonoscopy no I did one I've
never had anything major then the worst
thing I've ever had done probably is
like root canal I've never had any I
just want it to go away
well this is a test though that the
colonoscopy doesn't officially it just
kind of checks you know I suppose the
next few I have a live now are gonna be
all the years where all the
terrible things are gonna have to be
done to me on my adventure yeah those
off you wake up and you're fine okay
well what about the way back some people
do when I took propofol I was on 15
minutes later I felt fine the guts
everything's great do you have to prep
yourself like take off like this stop
the valium or whatever made everything
else what's the one kidney stones put a
tube in my in my in my in my penis
[Laughter]
because I had mine done in listo
lithotripsy I think it's called where
they put you in a when they put in the
time and they vibrate and explode oh
yeah they they can destroy the sphere
that it's tiny little bits of great
isn't it it's like a crystal well I was
pushing out I had a strainer I was
pissing out sand that was [ __ ] oh it
was coming out sand and and the world
huh but it worked oh yeah every kid that
can dissolve them they can destroy them
with ultrasound that they smashed up and
then you piss out and it hurt it hurt
yeah oh you got you've got a surgery up
the up no up the thing and they they
blast it with summer don't they what do
they do or they take do they remove it
or I don't know too much salt
what is it the calcium is what so what
causes kidney stones then calculation
what foods causes it Wow let's break
down what watching has calcium milk
Ryles dairy milk no but isn't it lack of
water as well can't you do it by just
because it's not flushing them out yeah
I think it's when you have kidney stones
you're supposed to drink like crazy
amounts of water that can do it as well
yeah because it's so you know that
can you imagine trying to pass a kidney
stone but it gets stuck halfway I'm sure
that happens halfway in you it's
supposed to be one of the most painful
things and watch you do an hour watching
me is like pissing a rock through your
dick there's no need for a tag we're
doing it toward that one coming up in
October so that was it cold creeps we
kids that's great yeah I love the photo
yeah it's gonna be great yeah hosted by
Jeffrey Epstein Ron bennington jim
Florentine
Bob five of us stand up you know clubs
until it happens don't a Montreal next
week you know is that just for loves
yeah yeah and you know my wife and I are
doing our scuba podcast here and don't
put yourself his wife the fact that they
don't have a show and it's I sound like
somebody's aunt saying that but they're
[ __ ] hilarious together and it shows
you how much show business stinks in
fact the human body don't have something
you do a documentary then just follow
each other down well we made that one
documentary called women aren't funny oh
yeah yeah in real well yeah and it was a
lot of us in it well we were supposed to
do a sequel a network held us for a year
don't we're gonna do it we're gonna do
it for a [ __ ] year and then they go
huh it should be just you and Bonnie
living your lives going like yeah two
comedians who literally did you wouldn't
have to force any of it for it we'd all
be legit you'd want someone to direct it
produce though just to keep it all
together just to but by money wants to
direct money right and directs Jesus had
a [ __ ] three page
in New York Times I mean amazing you
know I got one blurb that I'm a stage
hog but there was her I mean my wife is
[ __ ] brilliant a whole nother mystery
write scripts existence I know he's
holding her back
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
we're all just kind of waiting for like
the longer your bad behavior is
justified did you ask him why I only saw
that clip did you ask him why he started
going crazy in the first place in the
supermarket we talked about yeah it was
who was working there when the Indian
woman didn't understand egg whites that
he wanted and then when he asked three
times for egg whites and she turned
around she snickered and he said why are
you laughing at me and he said and
that's when the video starts I said his
whole life tired of it and this was just
one more example and just [ __ ] he
just snapped there's a whole bunch of
videos with it when someone does this
like he said he does it one to two times
a week he flicks yeah like it's not like
this was built up over years this was
probably four days he hasn't flipped out
he had anger built up he did it again he
had literally video after video of him
yelling at people
police had been involved multiple times
like he just is it about him being I'm
sure little guy yeah yeah yeah and so
and do you do you think that it's do you
think it's real that he does is
hypersensitive to it like he notices it
you know it's he's got anger issues yeah
right yeah it's real like his flip outs
are real that's another thing that I
think we were both oh really were to
figure out if this was fake or not it's
real of course now it's capitalizing on
it and yes exactly yeah but but yeah no
I get that if you had if you had 40
years of being treated like a
second-class citizen or a joke it would
it would but here's the thing the
punchline it doesn't get to us though it
doesn't get to know it does him but
here's you use it he took it and
empowered him selling literally
should've hung himself in 1985 turn
himself a great comment
yeah that's cuz I can't hang myself
without slipping through it thing about
bagel guy though that we found out
yesterday was that he was married for a
period of time and you know he's pissed
at the world cuz they all don't because
women don't like him because he's short
his physical of shortcoming is physical
shortcomings and we said what went wrong
between you and your wife and he said
when he met her his preference was women
with smaller breasts and then his
preference changed and he wanted women
with bigger breasts right so he and his
wife split up because her tits weren't
big enough yeah he kept harping on it
and she got annoyed hearing it and then
she finally Lane I do see people's
problems and I acknowledge them and
they're real but then it's something
like that like oh so this is your fault
as well but this is your sometimes badly
sometime the breasts will be small
yeah he's an [ __ ] who happens to be
short but I like the fact that that went
viral last week and the first thing you
to do is say get that get that guy from
the internet on I want to get his take
on this how did you even find him how'd
you even you see that sort of thing and
you go right who is this guy Travis how
did you get him Travis got him I think
right I saw men who's coming in that
morning he was outside like he must be
doing something oh you know no we've
been talking to him all weekend I didn't
do a ranger yeah I knew we were gonna
get him but I thought I didn't know we
had him yesterday so I'm not some
economy's do it how did you how did you
even find well luckily for us he did not
shy away from publicity no right
I decided he wanted to he wanted to lean
into this he wasn't shy about he didn't
go I don't want to talk about it he was
like I'd love to talk about this yeah
because he feels like a victim of the
whole thing he's not ashamed of his
actions he feels like it like you saw
just yeah well I suppose he treats it
like racism or he said he was the new
Martin Luther King which we all grew
[Laughter]
people to see standing up for people
they're short and get bullied and then
he said I'm a prophet
I'm the new Martin Luther King he said
I'm a prophet he said those words so he
thinks he's gonna come behind a podium
[Laughter]
so he was great he was absolutely I
enjoyed him I enjoy talking to him
issues but it was a van he said he
doesn't live in a van that's why his
wife left you know I don't think you
want to live in a van witness so did you
were you all clean and everything when
you met Bonnie then were you or yeah
that's all done four years right right
I've never seen me high no so yeah yeah
yet I'm just joking so I'm just
fascinated by it and I I see it more in
New York like all New York comics that
have sort of made it through and you
know I mean working comics they seem to
have had this thing that you know you
all went through yeah well I mean it's
don't admit as much we just carry on
together or die don't go to someone ray
you picked I don't go and tell someone
you're an alcoholic and you've got
problems that's embarrassing right carry
on or die right yeah yeah and if you die
you won't be embarrassed no exactly no
you'll be you know you'll be like mine
obsessed with the British comic hi Tommy
Cooper [ __ ] loved to pieces he was
really worried about her but just funny
just walked on sweaty and did you watch
him as a kid growing up yeah he was like
a mainstay he was like you know one of
the five comics that were always the
best to be on telly the whole family
loved him
your dad your granddad all the
kids loved him he was a clown it was
this guy the joke was that he tried to
do magic and he was terrible at it
he didn't and these jokes were terrible
but you're going on it says it was
things like I went the doctor I said the
doctor yes we were I do that and it said
don't do it dad jokes yeah yeah yeah
rapidfire and really [ __ ] it was
sweaty and out of control and his magic
tricks were just awful and I wouldn't
and you know he'd [ __ ] them up on
purpose er yeah so he was a he was like
but a big thing I've watched speeches
he's done like like it this thing where
he's presenting at this club and he's
being honored at this dinner and he's
just a funny dude why is no he had funny
bones and the everything he did was
funny
clowny and and yeah a sweaty ball of
fear it was that classic it's falling
down and failing for our pleasure right
you know I mean I thought it was no and
I think that I love that I you know I
there are these six slick comics we've
got um I'm hearing on there and they've
got a smart suit on they do great
one-liners and they write 50 a week but
it's exhausting
I want someone can come out and tell me
about what a bad day they've had that's
very like rich I know right yeah
genuinely yeah one I wanna I want the
comedian to leave something of himself
on the stage okay I want to get dirty
with his stuff whereas there's some
comedians that it's as good to read
their jokes as them do them we don't
need that your great great jokes but now
just leave the paper I'll read it on the
way home you're a writer
yeah yeah I know they think their job is
to teach you something and it's not it's
not it's nothing to do with them yeah
there's nothing that these these syntax
and semantics are nothing to do with
them I want someone spewing up their
[ __ ] guts
well the brain is to it there stood a
mechanic when I leave if I left a comedy
show I want to know that person yeah now
the whole crew we hung out with Norton
patrisse myself Carl and Bobby we're all
putting it out yeah well we're all
screwed up in some ways yes you [ __ ]
up yeah yeah and you don't have to be
[ __ ] up to be honest you could still
be honest ethical views of
honesty's funny you know honesty's funny
particularly if it's a taboo that's
already funny yeah but you know just our
whole crew is just broken toys
we're just broken and I'm laughing
because you're making great point and
you hit them but your fingers are so
short and you still manage to hit the
microphone while you're making these
great team would be to wear gloves just
talk three comics and ham Jim would you
would you have noticed the hitting of
the microphone yeah I did I noticed a
little thing but you know what what I
can do inaudible I know how to recover
to another big I still talked went on I
made my point but you mr. negative right
from you we're headliners we're talking
okay with different levels a headline on
every level of success there are comics
as good as everyone on every level I
agree so what what's what's the next
stage for you then - is it - is it to
get on I don't know anymore I don't know
what no I don't mean become it like it
is it still called to do seven minutes
on Fallon is that still I thought I owed
you out first why why do is best enough
[Laughter]
Jim already had another hurry I wish in
Atlanta and I'm trying to make this
restarting he's like when you watch a
[ __ ] Instagram video Atlanta we know
after reset every time Atlanta
established go
putting drinks you can hear glasses in
the back ice at my [ __ ] gigs you ask
where do I want to go exactly
I'd love to Sela we'd love to sell TV
Phil my wife and I are filled director
movie maker sequel to our other movie
right but because some people want to
get a TV show to sell more tickets some
people want to do gigs to get a TV show
and I don't I tape this hour we're
trying to sell it right like I said
before it was done at a convention no
one's ever done it
ever what conventions great and there
was under the audience were all in
recovering like right and I don't show
to your knees it's Bonnie directed the
opening was just [ __ ] amazing right
then we had a five camera shoot and
we're trying to sell it no one's ever
done I have a distributor but I'd like
to get it on Amazon or Hulu right
you know whatever show that awesome oil
and when you win you can you go to
Amazon or Netflix that is there is that
we don't want it or is there are we want
it but you're it's worth this is there
is no management's dealing with out but
I don't think they I think we've heard
we don't want it's the internet isn't it
so it's not that they've got they've got
likes but it's all there it's in the
cloud so you'd think they'd put a price
on it we don't want it unless it's this
cheap or we want it so much because what
does it cost to throw it up there
that's really funny to you to promote
it's always there that's the good thing
yeah about that but you want to get paid
for it otherwise you might as well put
on YouTube exactly yeah my goal is is to
hopefully sell this then also I'll bring
in a bigger audience and a lot of people
and recovery that will get material that
I don't do in a regular Club I could do
different besides what I do in a club I
could do expand and do what up and put
it around a documentary about it then
because we've already I didn't pay for
my management you know hate it's a five
camera shoot they had to edit it it's
because I didn't think of that
what's that no no because you could talk
to commerce about recovery and people
with that and there and then do your
bits on it and they could talk about
your bits on it and well how do we also
have a TV show attached to it right so
that could lead you know that could be
the interviews whatever yeah if it's
sold
then I'm going that direction buddy you
want but you wanna you want to do
stand-up every night I love stand yeah I
love it more than I did yeah the last
couple of years I'm sort of obsessed
with it the process and I love I love I
love the awkwardness and trying out and
bits vain I'm fascinated why when they
laugh at that bit so much I'm just I'm
really more and more fascinated by
bombing is kind of fun something neither
you do it on partly pond
your your try out things that didn't go
well that's amazing too many things up
there that and they're going pretty well
there okay if your topical I can't give
them for
all your duty is Game of Thrones joked
it's just so funny
thank you above your process it's great
because it's not like it's something I
keep like any other bits I'd love to put
up but I think I don't if I do
especially I want to save them but these
are all topical things that you know you
burn a topical thing in two weeks what
I'm gonna do with it I'm not gonna do on
a special we do the podcast just like
two hours but to get an hour together
it likes takes [ __ ] years what we
throw stuff away because it's it's not
that could you can't meander onstage in
the podcast we can mean yeah we could
talk for ten minutes rather laughs here
or whatever and yet with a new material
it wouldn't be like that it would be
trauma akin hard and you've got a whole
knit and it's not because they judge it
differently I think yeah but here's what
you did listen you just said what you
just said was a statement we're driving
a conversation we can't do that on stage
like you could just say something
without being funny that's
conversational and then we go into a
joke the pressure of being funny every
line isn't here but the audience doesn't
want to see us behind I think it's the
same reason that an ad-lib gets a round
of applause yeah cuz they know it's like
they give wit um more credit than hard
work but also to a comic if you think
something's funny yeah 9 and 99 out of
100 it's funny you know more than they
do you know what funny is the bad guy
you should be funnier than a regular
class I don't know if we if we know more
than it did because they [ __ ] like
what it's all about what's funny to them
like whatever they think we deliver
lines with a rhythm punch it should be
what's funny to you because you have to
live a no no I know what I'm saying is
what they interpret is being funny to
them is up to them also to their also so
some of them are politically correct
some of them won't laugh this additional
whatever well yeah you know one bit will
kill in one place
and then I did a bit last night it just
died but it always kills was a bit of
boy why is it cuz I talked about Gabi
guests know it's a true story but it's a
long bit about ron jeremy doing comedy
okay
and he walks on state he's an ex-porn
guy he walks on stage playing the
harmonica
then that's 10 minutes of unwatchable
comedy walks off playing a harmonica so
I went onstage after him and my this
happened yes actually yeah yeah and I
when I say to him and I said that
harmonica has AIDS
right because he's a porn star yeah but
I got offstage and there was a porn
actress in the back complaining that my
joke offended her yes I said hey a point
you know like [ __ ] triple anal my
joke offended you know somebody so the
bit when I do the bit the whole story
you add humor to it oh yeah I don't I'm
describing a terrible [ __ ] everyone
would anyone could come up to you and
say with any [ __ ] dignity that that's
offensive but that is amazing like see
that where this country's headed is that
I offended a porn star yeah of course no
this lady's [ __ ] you know all day
long but my joke [ __ ] difficult for
yourself you know what I mean so last
night in the land she knows a lot of
blue hairs and they hear and I go you
know when you burn a candle and you're
looking to base it a candle
you know her faces look like that after
understanding that because I said you
know she has a whole Jews face but there
are older ladies well I'm not trying to
do the bit on what I'm saying is well I
feel like I'm watching somebody just
spiral
captain Queen alright I told my do the
job I don't even get it exactly didn't
get the reference I don't know either
don't worry it's a Humphrey Bogart not
being topical I mean I've still got
Hitler all the way through my new funny
to watch yeah yeah I suppose you yeah I
don't do lots of different crowds I do
my crowd wherever I am in the world I'm
doing my crowd
so once some it works it sort of works
every night right for me you'll have to
prove to them you're finally they just
like yourself the bits good it's gonna
work well I think if if you if they
bought tickets to see you they already
want to laugh right yeah you just have
to corral them in you just have to give
them the rhythm and the punchlines and I
mean you have to do a lot more than that
but you know I mean it's not like
they're there if I walked onto someone
else's audience I'd struggle ever you
are you'd you'd have to win them over
that you know there's comics that are
just so different that you there's a
two-minute where they go whoa okay there
ski you can take a guy like Brian Regan
who's as funny as anybody and if he goes
on they don't know him I think he would
do well anywhere though Regan sister
[ __ ] yeah yeah I'm just saying as an
example you know your audience you know
when your intro is this your name then
you your want your you you once step up
you know concerns coming to see you
allow you to out you try out new
material on the road I'll throw it
because I'm doing it now or now on top
of that but they're coming to see you
you're not doing clubs on the road yes I
just ollie do as clubs and diners
at a time and I know if it does it
doesn't work I surround it by something
that's gonna work and I'll get to rhythm
down until I get it to work that's all
but is there a again um the club scene
it seems to be that you work in things
that were a topical when you first tried
them so you're doing stuff that's
happening in the world I don't do that I
try and make I try and do anything but
because I think I've got or this for a
long time then it's going on Netflix and
in three years time no one's gonna
remember this [ __ ] yeah oh yeah so I try
and so Hitler Holocaust rye to make a
person like say the lady that got kicked
off the plane for fat shaming was that
some lady was sitting between these two
messes and got up and oh yeah he was
sure though I don't mind that she got
kicked off it was all the social justice
warriors on the plane clapping that she
got kicked off yeah you know you go
[ __ ] go home and sleep between your
mattress and box spring and then tell me
what it's like to sit between two
[ __ ] you know what I mean it yes
uncomfortable
so you're sitting here talking about
this country on how the Directioners
going and how everybody is outrace
point-scoring that if they're outraged
they're outraged when they're not
outraged
yeah I agree okay so much there's so
much fake I mean even real outrage it
doesn't it's not a slam-dunk we can
still go I don't care yeah but a fake
outrage is actually annoying because I
think I think social media is sort of to
blame because they've got an audience
and they find their audience so now
they're playing to the crowd so now like
virtual signal I think is going look how
cool I am I pick this person up on a
thing that we don't like and it's there
it's like though there's low these clubs
there's these big mobs and clubs and
they saw they get a pat on the back and
a round of applause then they do it
again tomorrow they go looking for
somebody to get the pat on the back
again it's just like it's like a kid
going I was good at school I said this
about well done they they really I
really do think that it's point-scoring
now on social media here's you know you
know Barbie Barbie and Keith I'm
carrying kids around aa mob killing I
was working at the village underground
so I go on stage after a comic who says
funny as anybody Nikki Glaser is funny
dirty but funny and funny she goes on
and destroys you think she's funny
do you like her so Bobby and Keith go
they came over from Isola we go we're
gonna come over and watch you bomb they
used to say they used to come to watch
me bomb [ __ ] guys to do that's how I
grew up right off camaraderie taking the
piss what you know I'm a goddess to know
we've got a great assembly law we've got
an erection you know take a picture it
would be like having a dog but you still
have that yeah they come over so my
state she kills before she always so my
my first three jokes I get good laughs I
go I knew they were there I go look at
that one four one two three four three
all right I'm not gonna Bob so dad I did
it I didn't see this day one and what is
just with Amidala that you said that all
Monica's got AIDS for know how crazy so
I didn't see them they went on each side
of the room and then I did a dirty joke
and they groaned oh my god this is
amazing turned on me it was me in
Florentine ruin 2:45 minuts sent you did
it Caroline is doing that role in the
curtain yes [ __ ] 15 years ago oh
that's great what you do growing on
opposite sides of the curtain and he
[ __ ] you snapped for 45 minutes like
what the [ __ ]
headlining tonight and they uh you know
and you know they started like people
are so afraid to be the one person
laughing at the inappropriate times
right but all you need is one person to
groan and the entire room goes oh we
must be right I bet that none of your
friends has ever gone and started a
round of applause
[Laughter]
one more gemandsam catch up with full
episodes and interviews from celebrity
guests anytime on demand using the
SiriusXM app
[Music]